do you understand what it means to be
created in the image of God
I'm convinced that somewhere around 90
percent of the world's problems would be
solved if people would get their minds
around this one idea
and yet even the people who believe that
we're created in the image of God rarely
have any clue what that means
if you'd like to finally get it you're
about to get some help from an unlikely
Source a cancer-riddled comic genius
watch this till the end and you will see
the world a bit differently
[Applause]
back in September comedian Norm
Macdonald lost his battle with cancer
oh wait I forgot I'm not supposed to say
that I see in the old days a man could
just get sick and die you know now they
have to wage a battle and the reason I
don't like it is because in the old days
they go hey that old man died now they
go hey he he lost his battle
that's no way to end your life you know
what a loser that guy was
last thing he did was lose
so what should we say when someone dies
of cancer
and I'm pretty sure I'm not a doctor but
I'm pretty sure I mean if you die the
cancer also dies at exactly the same
time so that to me is not a lust that's
a draw that's a you know
comedian Norm Macdonald waged an epic
nine-year battle with cancer and fought
cancer to a draw that does sound better
but I'll tell you the more I hear about
cancer
the more I don't care for it
I've been watching Norm Macdonald for
years and when he died I ended up
watching a bunch of clips of him on
YouTube of course when you start
watching videos on a certain topic on
YouTube what does YouTube do it
recommends a bunch of other videos on
the same topic so for weeks YouTube was
giving me more and more Norm Macdonald
videos to watch eventually I watched
some videos usually Audio Only from
podcasts where Norm talked seriously
about God Jesus the Bible Christianity
Judaism the soul things like that and
it's interesting to hear him talk
seriously because usually if the topic
of religion would come up during an
interview he'd go into comedian mode
when he was being serious sometimes he
would say that he's a Christian other
times it sounded like he was closer to
Judaism still other times he would claim
to be some sort of generic theist
part of the reason for the shifting
positions was his methodology Norm was a
fan of intuition certain things seemed
true to him Based On A Feeling an
instinct hunch some sense of the way the
world is that wasn't based on reasoning
then he would reason based on his
intuitions and he would lean towards
whatever position fit his intuitions
best
let's go through an example of his
reasoning process Norm said he always
had an intuition that a personal God
exists
I just have an intuition that there's uh
that there's uh
a god when I say God I don't mean like a
force or something I mean an actual uh
personage
I just have this intuition that there is
one
like I've always had it
but he wasn't impressed with the
information you might find in gospel
tracks
everything I've read from
from religious tracks or stuff all seem
like insane to me
so I haven't really found one but um
but although I do I will say this of all
the religions
I like
Judaism and I like Christianity now
that's strange when someone gave him a
pitch for Judaism or Christianity in a
religious tract it sounded insane to him
and yet he said he liked Judaism and
Christianity what was going on here well
Norm had an intuition about man and
Judaism and Christianity fit his
intuition better than other ideologies
did his intuition was that human beings
are a kind of paradox in that somehow
were simultaneously something
spectacular and divine and something
horrible and depraved
but it's easy to emphasize either the
spectacular and divine aspect or the
horrible and depraved aspect
there are some people that believe that
like man is divine like like kind of a
hippie idea that we're all like
Beautiful Creatures so anyways I can't
believe that because I know my own heart
and I know that's not true
why are there people who think of human
beings as Divine sometimes even as gods
and goddesses temporarily trapped in
human bodies
well there's obviously a radical
difference between human beings and
other animals we have a constantly
expanding control over nature we have an
aesthetic sense that gives rise to Art
and music we use moral Concepts to judge
our actions we use logic and evidence to
evaluate arguments we understand
mathematics and philosophy and history
and science we explore the world we
explore the universe we explore the
cells in our body we're drawn to
something spiritual
were so obviously different from
anything else in nature that we seem
Divine by comparison
your breath
[Applause]
there's only one problem
most of us know ourselves well enough to
know that we really really suck
so enough of all this Unleash Your Inner
goddess nonsense we're terrible
and this leads to a completely different
understanding of human nature and then
like other people believe like we're
wretched like like the cynics you know
or the atheists or whatever would be
would would believe that we're all just
wretched like
nothingness you know we're just animals
just creatures so I can't believe that
that doesn't make any sense
you know they were just beasts
why are there people who think of human
beings as mere animals mere beasts
apart from obvious biological
similarities the simple fact is that
human beings often act like beasts even
when we use the abilities that set us
apart from other animals we end up using
them to satisfy the same drives that we
share with mere animals in other words
we use our capacity for creativity and
Innovation to produce the internet the
greatest information sharing revolution
in history and then we use the internet
to watch porn
but it gets worse because the abilities
that set us apart from other animals
allow us to behave far far worse than
the animals since Norm Macdonald was a
huge fan of Russian authors here's a
passage from dostoevsky's brothers
karamazov that Norm was quite familiar
with
by the way in Moscow not long ago a
Bulgarian told me Ivan went on ignoring
aliosha's remark of the atrocities
committed all over his country by Turks
and circassians who fearing a general
uprising of the slav population set
Villages of fire rape women and children
nail their prisoners to fences by the
ears and leave them in that state until
morning when they hang them and who
commit other atrocities that are
difficult even to imagine
people often describe such human cruelty
as bestial but that's of course unfair
to animals for no Beast could ever be as
cruel as man I mean as refinedly and
artistically cruel the tiger simply
gnaws and tears his victim to Pieces
because that's all he knows it would
never occur to a tiger to nail people to
fences by their ears even if he were
able to do it those Turks by the way
seem to derive a voluptuous pleasure
from torturing children they do
everything from cutting unborn babies
out of their mother's wombs with their
daggers to tossing infants into the air
and catching them on the points of their
bayonets as the mother's watch
it's doing this in front of the mothers
that particularly arouses their senses
but of the things the Bulgarian told me
the following seemed particularly caught
my attention
imagine a baby in the arms of his
trembling mother with Turks all around
them the Turks are having a little game
they laugh and tickle the baby to make
it laugh too finally they succeed and
the baby begins to laugh
then one of the Turks points his pistol
at the baby holding it four inches from
the child's face the little boy Chuckles
delightedly and tries to catch the shiny
pistol in his tiny hands suddenly the
artist presses the trigger and fires it
into the baby's face splitting his
little head in half
pure art isn't it
incidentally I understand that Turks are
very fond of sweet things
why are you telling me all this Ivan
aliosha asked
I think that if the devil doesn't exist
and is therefore man's creation man has
made him in his own image
just as he has created God in that case
yes I just quoted a passage from one of
Norm MacDonald's favorite authors which
talks about Satan being created in man's
image to help make a point in a video
about man being created in the image of
God
that just happened so in one sense man
seems amazing and divine when we compare
him with the rest of the natural world
and in another sense man seems depraved
and demonic when we compare him with the
rest of the natural world
man isn't one or the other he's both
simultaneously
the correct doctrine of man then needs
to account for both facts about man so I
will say that the Christianity has this
interesting
uh compromise where we're both Divine
and wretched
the other two are are both seem equally
untrue one that we're all Divine and
interconnected with nature just seems
like nonsense to me
the other that were Beasts of the field
seems like nonsense to me so I kind of
like that that Christian idea we're both
Divine and wretched here Norm is
referring to the doctrine in both
Judaism and Christianity that human
beings both men and women have been
created in the image of God but that
human beings have been corrupted by sin
let's have a quick crash course on this
topic and we'll see what Norm is getting
at
according to Genesis 1 26-28 Genesis 5
1-3 Genesis 9 6 and James 3 9 human
beings both male and female were created
in the image of God
but what does that mean
it means a lot of things but to get the
most basic meaning think about the role
of images in the ancient world
a king who ruled over an Empire would
have images of himself placed in cities
across the Empire as a reminder of his
authority and Dominion when you saw the
image of the king it reminded you of the
king if you were to defile the image of
the king that would be considered an
attack on the king
in the Bible God says that human beings
were created in His image so human
beings are supposed to be some kind of
reflection of God
now all of creation is a kind of
reflection of God's nature and
attributes but only human beings are
said to be created in God's image
so there's something special about the
way human beings reflect or image God
there are two basic ways that human
beings are the image of God one is
structural and the other is functional
this will be easier to understand with
an example
think of an airplane an airplane has a
function flying when an airplane is
functioning properly it flies
but an airplane can only function
properly if it has a certain structure
it needs the necessary Parts arranged in
the right way so an airplane has a
structure and a function
human beings also have a structure and a
function our most important function is
to image God we're supposed to make the
invisible God visible
and there are several ways that we can
do this God has Authority and dominion
over everything but he gives human
beings Authority and dominion over the
Earth we reflect god with our dominion
over the Earth
God is eternally a social being Father
Son and Holy Spirit have an eternal
loving relationship when God creates Man
In His Image he creates man as a social
being the Bible says male and female he
created them
we reflect God in the loving
relationships we have with other people
who are created in God's image
the most important relationship we can
have is a loving relationship with our
creator our love for God is a reflection
of God's love for us
when our lives are properly oriented
towards our creator we become like a
mirror that's positioned so that when
people look at us they see a reflection
of God
so we image God in our relationship with
God in our relationship with other human
beings and in our relationship with the
natural world that's our proper function
but notice we can only function in this
way because we have a certain structure
earlier we briefly discussed the
abilities and capacities that set us
apart from other animals our reasoning
ability our moral faculties our
aesthetic sense and so on these
abilities and capacities image God
because they're limited finite temporal
versions of God's attributes
so just as an airplane performs its
proper function when it flies we perform
our proper function when we have the
right relationship with God with our
neighbor and with nature
and just as an airplane can only
function properly because it has a
certain structure we can only function
properly because we have a certain
structure namely the various abilities
and capacities given to us by God so
that we can be his image
now that makes us sound like some
amazing creatures we can see why some
people are convinced that we're divine
why are we simultaneously wretched as
Norm says
well when human beings fall into sin and
Rebellion we take the abilities and
capacities that God gave us so that we
can be his image and we use them to
insult God and to degrade His Image
other human beings and ourselves
that's what makes us so incredibly
horrible we take something that was
given to us for a supreme good and we
use it for evil
it's like someone gives us money to open
a homeless shelter but we use it to
start a human trafficking ring
that's why we're simultaneously Divine
and wretched
but are we doomed to stay this way
are we stuck like this
or did the God who created us in His
image also make a way to restore the
proper functioning of his image
take it Norm and then there's this
middle man you see
that's the Savior that through him
we can we can become Divine but we're
born wretched and so uh it's a very
fascinating idea
I kind of like that one because it sort
of makes sense there you have it The
Gospel According to Norm Macdonald
I like that one too Norm
so God creates us with certain abilities
and capacities a certain structure so
that we can image God properly so that
we can make the invisible God visible on
Earth
but we use those abilities and
capacities for everything but Imaging
God properly we use those abilities and
capacities to try to keep God invisible
on Earth
but Christ the perfect image of God the
one who truly made God visible on Earth
restores our relationship with God and
by looking to Christ and imitating
Christ we grow in our ability to image
God until we're no longer the image of
God only in structure but also in
function
this has been affecting my view of the
world since the day I became a Christian
to see how just think about comedians as
an example
comedians can only do comedy because
they have abilities given to them by God
but they can use those abilities for
anything they want
they can use those abilities for
outright blasphemy the stand-up of Sam
Kinison is a good example here tons of
mockery of Jesus and the Bible
but in using the abilities given to them
by God in using their intellect and wit
and artistic sensibility even in using
their ability to speak which is also
given by God
they're still Imaging God even if
they're mocking God or degrading His
image
when we use the abilities that make us
like God in limited finite temporal ways
we image God
we may image God in a defective way but
we still image God
absorb this idea and you start to see
God everywhere not because everything is
God that would be pantheism but because
everything reflects God in some way
nothing as much as man does and no man
as much as Christ does
you can watch speeches by Richard
Dawkins and Sam Harris and all you'll be
thinking is
you guys are glorifying God in ways you
don't even realize
you can watch an episode of South Park
or a Quentin Tarantino movie and every
time you see the work of a creative
genius you understand that the genius
himself is the work of an even greater
genius
you can go on Twitter and see the
endless bickering as people try to
demonstrate their Worth to their group
by attacking the right people and all
you see is God
all people image God they just image him
in defective ways but once you
understand the ways in which they're
defective you just see the image
of course it's much better when someone
is Imaging God properly even if it's
only for a few minutes of a podcast
and to hear clips of Norm Macdonald
arguing for the existence of the Soul or
responding to the problem of evil even
though his arguments were pretty sloppy
by the standards of a philosopher to
hear Norm fumbling his way towards the
almighty because of the inclination that
God gave him to do that
it makes us think that Norm at least at
times
was the image of God in a better sense
than most
I'd like to image God in some videos
how are you going to image God today
[Music]